L Senator Lindsey Graham South Carolina
is with us so you got Syria firing
Rockets you got the houti firing Rockets
you got Hezbollah and the north firing
Rockets out of Lebanon you got Hamas in
Gaza uh add to that now erdogan uh
threatening to join in and you got the
Iranians threatening to join in um I
don't think it's been this bad uh
Senator and um I don't really see any
other option except Israel destroys
Hamas and Hezbollah and anybody else
that joins in well let's look at it this
way I just got back from Israel about 3
days ago what I saw I really don't sleep
well anymore I I saw things that I
didn't think one human being could do to
another uh Hamas outd did the Nazis uh
they cut uh babies out of the wom of the
mother yeah yeah so if I were the uh uh
Israeli ambassador of the UN I would
take all this and show it to the UN
Security Council when the UN Security
Council voted for a ceasefire before the
Israeli bodies had been buried it made
me sick to my stomach it would be like
telling America after Pearl Harbor we
need to ceasefire with the Japanese
here's what I would do uh if I were
president of the United States I would
tell Iran there's any more attack on our
troops in Syria and Iraq you will be out
of the oil business I will tell Iran
that Hezbollah uh front opens up against
Israel you'll be out of the oil business
that we will declare you the enemy of
the United States we will destroy your
ability to finance terrorism anything
short of that and I love Oliver North
but the the Hamas could give a damn
about the Palestinians they're not going
to trade hostages for innocent
Palestinians they could care less about
the Palestinians they want to kill all
the Jews they're the modern-day version
of of Nazis they can only be dealt with
by destroying them Israel take all the
time you need and do whatever it takes
to destroy Hamas that's nonnegotiable
for me to Iran if you attack one more
American if if one American gets injured
or dies because of your puppets in Syria
and Iraq I'm going to be putting all the
pressure I can on President Biden to
attack Iran if there's another front
opening up against Israel Iran you will
pay the price go to the source of the
evil the great Satan in the world is
Iran it's not Israel it's not the United
States weakness breeds more aggression
we have a chance to turn this around now
we should have a rally on the mall of
the capital up here singing the Praises
of our friends in is they're too busy
there are too many um let's just say
virent anti-semitic comments all over
our country in the world Senator it's
never been this bad yeah go to hell in
our let me just tell you about the UN
right now it is the most anti-Semitic
body on the planet to ask Israel to have
a ceased fire after their people were
slaughtered more viciously than the
Nazis having children beheaded women
raped in front of their parents the un
is wrong here's when we'll have a
ceasefire when Hamas ceases to be a
threat to Israel then and only then we
will have a ceasefire Senator Graham
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else